Sean bienvenidos a un episodio más de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro Cordero cada 11 de Julio Naciones
Unidas conmemora el llamado día mundial
de la población una fecha en la que se
intenta concienciar sobre los desafíos
que entraña la superpoblación la
distribución de recursos y las
consecuencias que tiene para el futuro
de nuestra especie y el planeta el
crecimiento progresivo del número de
personas este año se realiza además
después de que el pasado 15 de noviembre
se superase por primera vez los 8 mil
millones de personas vivas Pero por qué
se eligió este día para entenderlo toca
remontarse hasta el 11 de julio de 1987
en esa fecha se alcanzaron los 5.000
millones de seres humanos sobre la
Tierra una cifra récord para la época
que empezó a poner en alerta a Naciones
Unidas a partir de 1989 debido a las
previsiones que se proyectaban sobre el
crecimiento poblacional y las
consecuencias que tendría para el
planeta y sus recursos En las siguientes
décadas Especialmente cuando se calculó
que la población podría doblarse Y es
que el crecimiento numérico de nuestra
especie desde inicios del siglo XIX ha
sido exponencial
desde su origen el ser humano no ha
parado de aumentar su población salvo en
un par de periodos como el de la peste
de Justiniano entre los siglos vi y 8 o
la peste negra en el 14 pero es a partir
de 1800 cuando la situación cambió de
hecho en 1803 alcanzaron por primera vez
los mil millones de personas y 125 años
después en 1928 ese número se dobló
hasta los 2000 millones a partir de ahí
cada vez se tardaban menos años en
aumentar en mil millones la población
humana hasta que en el año 2022 se
alcanzaron los 8.000 millones de seres
humanos unos datos que las proyecciones
mantienen al alza ya que a partir del
año 2050 se estima que habrá unos 9.700
millones de personas en el planeta y
para finales del siglo se alcanzarán los
10.900 millones de personas
las causas de este aumento a partir del
siglo XIX son claras las mejoras en las
condiciones de vida Gracias a la
revolución industrial El Avance de la
ciencia la agricultura masiva el
saneamiento de las aguas El Avance en
las vacunas y el creciente número de
personas que llegan a la edad
reproductiva pero esta mejoría no se dio
en todo el planeta a la vez los primeros
en experimentarla fueron la mayoría de
países europeos y Estados Unidos estos
países fueron los primeros en tener un
Boom poblacional desde finales del siglo
XIX hasta la mitad del 20
en las sociedades antiguas las tasas de
mortalidad y natalidad eran altas Pero
cuando hubo mejorías las tasas de
mortalidad se desplomaron y las de
natalidad se mantuvieron elevadas Esto
es lo que llevó al nacimiento de la
explosión demográfica esto se puede ver
mejor en el siguiente gráfico en el
régimen demográfico antiguo se pueden
ver las dos líneas la de mortalidad y la
de natalidad en un en un plano elevado
pero en el período de transición Se
observa un espacio que es el crecimiento
poblacional explosivo y es gracias a esa
bajada en la tasa de mortalidad después
de esta fase de transición se puede
apreciar como la tasa de natalidad
también decae una vez se llega al
régimen demográfico moderno todos los
países han atravesado estas estos datos
los están atravesando o los atravesarán
en un momento diferente entre cada uno
de ellos
por eso después de esa fase de Gran
crecimiento en Europa y Estados Unidos
otras regiones del planeta
experimentaron lo mismo en el último
tercio del siglo XX como América Latina
o el sudeste asiático y otras como las
que pertenecen al continente africano
recién están iniciando esta fase de
crecimiento explosivo sin embargo una
vez se alcanza el régimen demográfico
moderno las poblaciones se estancan o
decrecen este fenómeno va paralelo al
aumento de la esperanza y la calidad de
vida en esos países por eso desde hace
décadas la población europea está
prácticamente estancada y en países como
china se está empezando a vivir un
fenómeno muy parecido
esto se ejemplifica en el siguiente mapa
para que exista un crecimiento natural
positivo cada mujer debe tener unactasa
de hijos de un 2,1%, Eso quiere decir
que se podrá realizar ese reemplazo
generacional para que una nación siga
creciendo en población como podemos ver
Europa registra tasas de fecundidad
extremadamente bajas y ya desde hace
bastante tiempo pero este mismo fenómeno
Ya se está empezando también a replicar
en otras partes del planeta como podemos
observar en América o incluso en Asia
Entonces ustedes se preguntarán por qué
sigue creciendo la población global Pues
básicamente lo hace por las altas tasas
de fecundidad que se concentran sobre
todo en el continente africano como
podemos ver muchos de esos países tienen
hasta un 5 hasta 5 hijos por mujer de
tasa de fecundidad Entonces es aquí
donde está el mayor desafío de cara al
futuro según Naciones Unidas
entonces a pesar de que el crecimiento
poblacional se ralentiza el número de
seres humanos seguirá aumentando hasta
finales de este siglo especialmente
entre los países más pobres
décadas en las que se presentarán varios
retos a nivel global que probablemente
generen tensiones el más importante sin
duda es cómo resistirá el planeta a más
de 10.000 millones de personas con
necesidades de abastecimiento de
alimentos y agua especialmente en
décadas en las que el cambio climático
golpeará con fuerza regiones con gran
tasa de crecimiento como África una
situación que puede que lleve a
movimientos migratorios y conflictos
armados por los recursos más básicos con
esto concluimos si quieren conocer más
historias sigan conectados a France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]